in Avengers infinity war the evil
villain Thanos likely draw inspiration
from Malthus like Thanos Malthus was
convinced the population growth without
pace growth and living standards leading
to disaster
unlike Thanos Malthus did not use a
magic glove to kill half the universe
but Thanos and Malthus are wrong as
technology improves sodas efficiency
Earth's population has grown
significantly over the centuries the
calories are more available and extreme
poverty more scarce than ever before
the key reason efficiency and
productivity gains and innovation allow
living standards to grow faster than the
population instead of delivering death
and destruction
Thanos should focus on increasing
productivity innovation and efficiency
specifically he should encourage rule of
law strong liberal institutions and an
entrepreneurial culture break down trade
barriers between planets and galaxies
deregulate businesses lower the
corporate tax rate on each and every
planet patent reform and of course
generous funding for scientific research
here's hoping the Avengers stop Thanos
in the next film they are on the side of
the best social and economic analysis
the internet tells me that some of you
think Fanus did nothing wrong why let us
know in your comments also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI